it's been 16 years since Keanu Reaves
put down his leather duster and
sunglasses as he walked away from his
role as neo in the matrix trilogy but
now that he's returning to the familiar
dystopian universe to become the one
once again in the matrix for he's
sharing his thoughts on the new film
chatting with Entertainment Tonight
we have spoke up about the script for
the fourth Matrix film which was
officially announced in august 20 1944
Semper Fi the upcoming British drama
film produced by his sister Corina
Miller
he told et that he'd read the script for
the matrix for are you happy with her
neo is where would you like to see me
yeah no absolutely it's very ambitious
admittedly there isn't a lot to go on
with Reeves comments but it's still
thrilling to hear that he's getting
pumped up about returning to one of his
many career defining roles Plus
ambitious is definitely an interesting
word considering that the original
Matrix trilogy changed the sci-fi movie
genre ultimately defining an entire era
of action sequences special effects and
world-building though very little is
known about the matrix for yet we do
know that the film is set to push even
more boundaries and deliver insightful
incisive and interesting commentary on
our current society as lana wachowski
noted when announcing the matrix for the
ideas that she and her sister lily
explored 20 years ago with the first
film are even more relevant now when the
first matrix film hit theaters in 1999
audiences were blown away by the
extraordinarily intricate world which
presented a reality that wasn't actually
real the world everyone thought they
were living in was revealed to be a
computer simulation created by machines
that humans tried to overpower
everything in this fake reality is
created for humans by those computers
when he's given the chance to escape the
matrix and learn the truth
neo sees the dark real world where the
Sun is blotted out and humans must
survive by hiding from the machines both
inside and outside of the matrix itself
in the end it turns out neo is the one a
faded hero who can actually control the
matrix while within the simulation
thereby being the only person who has
any hope of stopping the machines in
their tracks
after the Matrix Reloaded was released
in 2003
the trilogy seemed like it came to a
definitive end with the matrix
revolution
which hit theaters later that same year
at the conclusion of revolutions neo
sacrifices himself to save humanity and
bring an end to the human and machine
conflict with a conclusion that final it
seems strange that Reeves could possibly
return for a fourth installment but we
know that both Reeves and carrie-anne
moss are firmly aboard the matrix for
and will reprise their roles as
characters who were last seen dying
so clearly the minds behind the new film
found a way to resurrect neo and Trinity
Reeves has certainly kept busy in the
years since he last played neo
after appearing in various romantic
comedies as well as Richard Linklater's
adaptation of A Scanner Darkly he
produced a documentary entitled side by
side and earned his first directing
credit on the underrated man of Tai Chi
however thanks to two stuntmen from the
original matrix films Reeves returned to
his action roots in 2014 with John wick
which ended up becoming its own trilogy
alongside these butt-kicking projects
Reeves has taken the time to appear in
some comedic projects as well he starred
in destination wedding and made
self-parody and cameos and the Netflix
original films always be my maybe and
between two ferns the movie he may have
bounced around genres since the Matrix
trilogy wrapped but Reeves has planted
himself firmly in the pop-culture canon
with his recent film appearances there's
truly no better time than now for a
Reeves led matrix for and we can't wait
to see what it's like check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bells so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]